colorado governor jared polis just
announced that the state of colorado is
now going to begin accepting bitcoin for
tax payments starting in the summer of
2022. now jared polis is a very
interesting character when it comes to
bitcoin he was the first politician in
the united states to actually accept
bitcoin as part of his campaign
donations going all the way back to
2014. and so obviously jared polis as
the governor of colorado he's pro
bitcoin he understands what this
decentralized digital currency means for
the world now if we go ahead and we take
a look at the exact quote that he used
it's very telling he said the state
would not hold any of the assets in
crypto those would be instantly
converted back into dollars when the
transaction occurred the government
would not be interested in participating
in the speculative aspects positive or
negative we would simply use it as a
means of exchange for purposes of
payment now this is interesting because
obviously he understands bitcoin he's
accepted bitcoin as a campaign donation
but he also understands that he's
operating in a conservative environment
of politics and if he's seen to be
speculating on the price of these assets
that won't be good and likely he'll
receive pushback both from his own
political party and also the other side
of the aisle and so being able to accept
bitcoin as an exchange of payment for
those taxes but convert it into us
dollars gives him the ability to walk
the middle of the road use bitcoin as a
means of exchange but also not speculate
on price if we look at colorado they're
not exactly a small state when it comes
to actual revenues from taxes there's 58
billion dollars in combined state and
local general revenues that came from
taxes in 2019 which comes out to about
10 000
per individual within the state and so
ultimately this is exactly what i expect
to see across every single state we saw
previously the state of ohio josh mandel
who's a treasurer there made it possible
for businesses to pay business taxes in
bitcoin that was rolled back by the next
treasurer who came in but the state of
colorado going big and looks like
they're going to get this through where
they will allow any single person within
the state to use bitcoin for tax
payments if that begins in the summer of
2022 over the next five to six years i
expect other states to follow suit and
if that occurs it will simply be another
milestone in the adoption of bitcoin as
a global reserve currency and also as a
medium of exchange and store value
bitcoin is inevitable bitcoin is good
for business and now the state of
colorado and their governor they're
getting on board as well